kangaroo's great at jumping around and
stuff and eating the tar out of each
other apparently real good at that but
kangaroos aren't so great at climbing
trees that is safe for one group that
has mastered the art the unimaginative
Lee named tree kangaroos spend their
lives 100 feet high in the rainforests
of Australia and New Guinea compared to
their cousins on the ground their legs
are shorter allowing for better
maneuverability they can also walk
backwards unlike regular roots which can
only manage full steam ahead and check
out their huge claws that help them get
a grip in the canopy really though a
climber is only as good as the tree it
climbs branches can still snap from
under the kangaroo luckily these things
are crazy tough if a predator is closing
in the root can reportedly leap 50 feet
out of a tree and land without totally
shattering its lower body but normally
they're grazing peacefully on all manner
of veggies from leaves to shoots and
their favorite of all are flowers from
the sweet hands of royalty eat up
peasant and don't you dare look them in
the eye